there's a lot of old entire comedy and
media entertainment that makes fun of
Asian men for not being sexually
attractive we decided to bring in for
everyday Asian American guys to recreate
iconic underwear ads who represent a
wide diversity of body types sexuality
and just general amounts of [ __ ] ability
I've also invited some my Asian American
male colleagues across entertainment and
media to provide some context to this
experiment that's right
context because Asian men have sex a lot
of sex which explains why there are
billions of us gentlemen welcome we are
here today to talk about why the [ __ ]
aren't Asian men considered sexy there's
only four left in that song average
Asian American male is never really
spoken to and what's interesting is I
feel like the average male in other
cultures specifically let's say with
white American culture is constantly
spoken to like the idea of being an
average Joe is literally almost a badge
of honor you even see more diversity of
size and shape and so forth among
African Hispanic actors at least in
comedies right if you are an Asian lead
you have almost happy super hot today
I'm recreating the David Beckham Armani
ad I was born like too much premature
with a cleft lip and palate
growing up I'd never liked my face
because it's not symmetrical and that
compounding it with my mom like I she
always meant well but she's like oh you
have a round face like you need to work
out a lot we all are kind of ascribing
to these Western ideas of beauty and so
like I still have a lot of insecurities
about it I get the gift of recreating
the infamous Justin Bieber at I was in
high school and you know the jokes start
flying around when the body started
getting the girlfriends and even though
I am a man I don't fit the prescribed
notion of what is sexy because I don't
look like the Ryan Gosling's with Tom
Brady's I didn't realize how different I
was because I was an Asian American like
people talk about kpop as if it's going
to save the world right like Asian idols
from Asia are going to make it all good
for the rest of us and the fact is as
much as I appreciate that it's kind of
cool that it's being imported here it's
again one of the things which doesn't
quite solve it for just
the day Asian guys in the middle of
America
I am recreating the famous Marky Mark
Wahlberg Calvin Klein ad where he's
grabbing his junk
I wasn't skinny ass kid attractiveness
is how chiseled is your chest you know
how nice are your abs like my mom will
say like you should be skinnier you
should be slender and I was like
Comstock I'm not you know 155 pounds but
what's the big deal India doing well and
like all these macho Abhishek Bachchan's
and John Abraham who are like the Tom
Cruise's and Brad Pitt's of India still
have nothing to do with my life
I'm recreating the guy from Fifty Shades
of Grey I was born raised in Iowa so
like there was that dynamic of just
being kind of the only South Asian so it
does suck that like attractiveness is
something that's so valued like the
everyday of an Asian American man
doesn't get much like love or respect to
give this some context when these types
of videos or projects are initially
constructed BuzzFeed is one of the main
contributors to this you respond to any
sort of prejudice with hot asian guys
that can disprove this theory of age men
on hot but all those men have
traditional features that play into a
Western male ideal I haven't really seen
any Asian males on an underwear campaign
I just think they're not represented
because the stereotype a body type right
slender small build we're going to have
to just create a little bit of the
shorter structure maybe I won't have to
phone I'm gonna give you the confidence
that you need to become Jaime fifty
shades of gray for me I just like my
body is not shaped that way I've never
been like swole or whatever so I just
think about like every relationship that
I've been in has ended on just some
vague term of like you're great but it
is just something missing
and so I wonder if it's like that last
little facet of just like pure
attractiveness even for Justin Bieber
this person was so celebrated even he
isn't perfect I hope to reaffirm the
idea that there is strength and
vulnerability if I look in the mirror I
would like to see the person looking
right back at and I am
so nervous haha yes we have a unicorn
you know I mean it's like they're
genetically gifted people of every
ethnicity but no question about that but
it doesn't adjust the larger reality
that we live in a culture in which the
basic standards you know not the ones
that we can expire - not the ones that
it'd be you know Jim ratted all of our
lives and were born with right parents
all that stuff whatever like the basic
standards what an Asian guy looks like
probably fall short in different way
it's not ever going to be comfortable to
be doing this I kind of wish I was doing
it you know when Mark Wahlberg was 21
even bodybuilders like you know it's
never good enough even though their
bodies are perfectly sculpted I think
personally for me in terms of what I
want to achieve for this video is just
kind of being more comfortable with my
body David Beckham is the epitome of
this European like embodiment of
masculinity I think what I'm nervous
about this photo is am I going to be hot
enough to represent Asian American
masculinity in this photo you never ever
get to see these images and media of
like an asian guy you grew up with or
your brother or your father with media
in this country because it has been
predominantly white and I get like you
know I'm sure like some people are like
how talking about not being white but
when you're not the majority in it you
have to have that visibility just you
can show people like it's not the only
option if you like that great but like
it can't be the only thing you see we
got the set ready and we're going to
want to see if I can look like this
fifty shades guy the facial expression I
will be helping you along the way
coming into young adulthood where I was
very much questioning like your your
self value as an attractive person
because you just don't fit that
particular mold every day people are
freaking beautiful you know like that
should also be a part of the
conversation in terms of attractiveness
I'm hoping that that can it just gives
me more confidence in myself my body my
melanin to keep just kind of expand our
idea of what attractiveness could be
apparently try to over exaggerate your
muscles pushing it to 110
no pipeline one key do you want a buddy
off it all you got to do is get it out
all day every single Asian American
should feel comfortable in their own
skin regardless and out of what
perception is head hit this way the
other way like this place
fur your brow a little bit a little bit
more less back but like normal they
wouldn't be a lot harder than you think
getting it exactly you know tilted a
certain way or thank you has to be this
way in me auntie it's about you and how
you feel not well you know Asian guys
are typically small and crying like why
do you look so big like maybe you should
you know slow down a little
I hope I do much more proud very kind of
subtle way this exercise just putting
Asian guys who are just everyday Asian
guys into this frame they may not look
like the ripped athlete or the
supermodel but maybe it'll make somebody
turn around face you know that guy too
bad
head down 11 we're identifying as an
LGBT man and being asian-american it
compounds certain qualities of
masculinity it's given merit because
you're able to pass in a heteronormative
society you think of every kind of
movement that you do and how is that put
under this microscope that we have
created Lanskaya t this is getting very
difficult and when people contact me are
you contacting me because your
fetishizing me are you contacting me
because i'm the exception to this asian
idea that you have so it's always a kind
of second guessing as well as being an
asian-american time for me to get into
my tiny white 10m keep in mind that he
was photoshopped if you don't get too
stressed out about the muscle thing oh
my god these images on social media you
get a set up and you get to look perfect
and that fantasy is what so many people
work on to wake up every day believing
that that is what i need to achieve that
is so exactly to think about okay
perfect I think we got it
with what's out there generally media we
don't see much supporting the average
asian male being
six Cod right because we're being
realistic like anyone can't just be an
underwear model you know the way that
the fashion industry and I think
especially this kind of fashion works is
they're going to look for a certain type
there's the Victoria's Secret type and
there's the you know the obsession
immunity I see the Calvin Klein kind of
underwear type and the reality is you
know yeah that's like tiny tiny micro
fragmented population we know we can
easily go to like a modeling agency and
get the people who are equally ripped as
any other ethnicity and it'd be perfect
for it what we're seeing is like with
these four guys like people who are of
like just normal people and you're right
we don't see that though in regular
underwear ads anyway I think that they
just need to focus on seeing the
underwear on what ideally fit healthy
people want to be it's been one week
we're about to do the reveal you know
I'm not gonna lie of course I feel a
little bit nervous when I look at this
photo of mocking mark immediately the
first thing you're going to think of
this is just what a real man supposed to
look like is that all that chef there me
or did you guys like highlighted to make
sure that make you look like it's like
more popping out if you were to tell me
that I'd probably be my underwear
recreating one of the most famous
underwear ads a week ago I would
probably have been like I'm not doing
that but I mean looking at it now it
turned out better than I expected
right before review it I feel a little
excited a little nervous there's no way
it looks like this
you can just it's like that exact
structure of the like attractive
specimen and so naturally when I see
myself my own body it's just like not
this doesn't check these same boxes
oh my god my eyes are just drawn first
to like blemishes I like this what is
that called that's a muscle right I mean
when we put them side by side I don't
really see much of a similarity that's
not to say that this isn't as attractive
ultimately it's just very contextual
like what is attractive if this never
comes out and this is the ad like maybe
there's a shot at that being the ideal
of attractiveness we are given an
opportunity now is just as Asian men in
Western media to say we can be hot any
one of us can feel and express ourselves
in a sexual way and it's not weird and
it's not a gimmick it's just who we are
I can feel my heart racing like oh my
gosh man we want to look at this like
just being with confidence and I'm
supposed to strive to emulate that and
that's so much pressure all right oh my
god you know that's not at all that
photo I'd see my imperfection and this
body is not picture-perfect
seeing it side by side and it's also bad
actually changing in that like a little
bit more of ownership it's like yeah
this is my body you got to be able to
feel comfortable in your own skin to
express who you are David Beckham is a
lot to live up to and this kind of like
unreachable sexiness I'm really worried
that I'm going to look like I'm trying
to do all these things but not exactly
succeeding yeah I never like pictures of
myself and I like this picture like I
feel empowered in this I don't feel less
than after seeing this picture look I
know that I'll never be this like David
Beckham masculinity but I think seeing
this picture actually like lets me kind
of own a piece of my own masculinity
there's so many definitions of what's
being attractive is and Asian men
definitely fit in those definitions no
matter what your body type is
how you bloke what you have to offer in
here is a lot more important than the
size of your biceps or your abs or how
many times you can push a weight up and
down look I'm sure mark your mark you
know has body insecurities and regards
to nought of how short how tall how how
skinny you are I mean the most real
thing you can do is to love yourself
love your body and just forget about
everyone else I think regardless of what
an Asian man looks like we all have sexy
qualities about us this is such an old
archetype of like the only way a man can
be attractive this has equal value to be
able to change is to be fluid and to be
fluid games that you can exist in
different contexts which i think is so
important especially for Asian American
men as we move forward in our definition
or redefining of masculinity if you
could say one thing to sort of round out
this conversation what would you say
like an Asian guy literally hasn't got
yuria
Wow